[Music]
hello and welcome to drive at the DW car
show coming up a look ahead at the 2018
formula e LD presents its team and
racecar a colorful designer car a
special edition of sit wins ds3 and
Kia's new stomach SUV yes car tester
honey left stick observes that kia two
is writing the SUV waive the stomach is
Kia's fourth SUV as a subcompact
crossover this new one is meant to
appeal mainly to young buyers the
Koreans have gone all out with this
little SUV the stomach's lifestyle
factor is calculated to lure buyers away
from the renewal Cup tour and the
pre-show 2008 the message is simple the
mini SUV can take the place of a compact
station wagon or van the stunning
features the popular high seat position
coveted SUV look and relatively generous
space
[Music]
donek brownie notes that the stomach has
the kia rios platform and interior which
means kia has succeeded in putting a low
weight crossover on the market depending
on the engine the vehicle waste between
1145 and 1300 49 kilos less weight on
the front axle means better feedback
from the suspension and more agility on
the road the 1-liter 3-cylinder
turbocharged engine we tested achieved
88 kilowatts and serves the 1.2 tonne
stomach very well a top speed of 185
km/h is more than sufficient for a
subcompact SUV its average fuel
consumption that's rated at 5 liters per
100 kilometers but 3 cylinder engines
can never be really quiet and the kia
stomach is no exception the Asian design
team led by veteran German automotive
designer paid to Schreyer tailored a
body for the just 4.1 4 meter stunning
that's not so very different from any
other sub compact SUVs yet it still
features a number of eye catchers
[Music]
the cockpit amounts to a well-organized
workspace with a touchscreen mounted
front and center the materials and
workmanship are quite solid basic
equipment on the stomach includes the
infotainment system with apple carplay
and android auto and of course air
conditioning
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
with volumes ranging from 352 to 1155
liters the luggage space is average for
the class folding the rear seats down
gives you a flat slightly inclined load
bed for an even classier look a two-ton
color scheme is optional Kia has never
been this customizable before at least
on the exterior
[Music]
the stomach is a cool smart SUV with the
right proportions and design all around
the subcompact crossover with the 62
kilowatt 1.2 liter engine starts at
fifteen thousand seven hundred ninety
euros in Germany the 1 liter
turbocharged version we tested lists for
twenty one thousand eight hundred ninety
euros
[Music]
the Stein's the brawny concludes the
Kia's SUV and crossover family's
smallest members brimming with
self-confidence the choice of 29 single
and two-tone paints three interior color
schemes and four equipment packages
definitely has something for everyone
[Music]
howdy motorsport division II Ringo stamp
of area is packed today for the
presentation of a new race car which
outing intends to enter in the formula
II World Championship in the coming
season
and when formula e is a new race series
for all electric powered formula cars
the first season began in September 2014
last season Team Audi Sport at
Schaeffler wrapped up the overall title
[Music]
racing paper mountains a board member of
Audis technical development division
says racing is in the company's DNA
electric mobility is important to the
company so of course it's taking part in
the formula e an extremely interesting
platform in the long term developments
in Motorsports fuel developments in cars
for volume production
[Music]
thirty mountains explains that the
extreme conditions of racing can teach
the company a lot about the life cycles
of components about how the battery
holds up and about the interplay between
engine transmission and battery so the
racetrack is like an experimental and
fulfills howdy gives 100% support to the
racing team hans-juergen apt founded in
2014
[Music]
the head of Audis motorsport division d2
gus calls out easy throng fe0 for a
fantastic vehicle you don't see much
difference from the outside he says
because the chassis and body are the
same as out of used in season three but
underneath the carbon fiber chassis
everything is new the company worked on
every system that was open to
development especially the motor
generator unit and the transmission and
then the speedster rolls up howdy is
counting on the abilities of Schaeffler
technologies which produces drive trains
people goods my says Schaeffler and the
racing team developed a completely new
powertrain without one speed
transmission the engine was completely
revised for greater efficiency
he says Schaeffler is an old hand in its
field but still learned a lot this
season there was enough room to improve
everything including the engines
efficiency and dynamics if it's in
genomic under the name out eSport app
Schaeffler the team will start in the
new season's first race on December 2nd
in Hong Kong current world champion and
ex Formula One driver Lucas di Grassi
compares the two racing series
there is a lot of differences between
formal and formally what is the same is
the technique to drive this car fast so
to drive any car fast you have to apply
a certain technique and the difference
for people-watching
is that form ie only races in cities so
all the races are like Monaco the car is
100% electric the difference between the
cars are much smaller so the races are
much more competitive dependent it's
much more dependent on the driver as
last year's victor de Grassi is the man
the other drivers aim to be he views the
coming season soberly these good to say
impossible to say of course we're gonna
fight hard of course we're gonna work
hard but it's impossible to set the
stage howdy motorsport manager de gas
expresses more optimism in the figure
were the ones they're chasing certainly
he says but howdy never enters a racing
category just to have been there but
always to win and this year is no
exception
he thinks out he has a good foundation
to build on and strong driver experience
so it has good chances for victories
next year the company's commitment to
the formula e makes it the german auto
industries electric mobility pioneer BMW
Mercedes and Porsche won't be far behind
fifthly has rolled out its new
continental grand tourer the luxury
coupe pays 467 kilowatt engine achieves
a top speed of 333 km/h on the road on
this latest model the front axle has
been moved forward by 13 and a half
centimeters giving it a longer hood and
flatter front the interior is all new
cutting edge and digitally upgraded the
2 by 2 seater offers heated and
ventilated massage seats and a luxury
feel good atmosphere BMW has given a
preview of its new top model in the
x-family the x7 concept high performance
the car makers first high-end SUV is a
plug-in hybrid powered by a combination
gasoline and electric engine on electric
drive the x7i performance puts out zero
emissions the SUV seats up to six people
Beamer will be presenting the production
model x7 next year
[Music]
this contest arena's Pete Lee is certain
the version of said twins ds3 that she's
trying out is a woman's car one clue is
a picture of a font called Leon on the
key Leon this little deer is the logo of
French designer in ASDA Lafleur saunch
she was a model and an inspiration for
Karl Lagerfeld and then became a fashion
designer herself
now she's partnered with Sue twins
high-end sub-brand es to create a new
look for the ds3
on the outside it's identifiable by the
red mirrors the red wheel hub logos and
the blue white and red striped rim
inspired by old airmail envelopes
running along the rear windshields
bottom edge
[Music]
the opal white roof with a third brake
light integrated in the rear spoiler
sets a modern contrast to the dark blue
body
[Music]
buyers confused between a 73 kilowatt
engine with automatic transmission and
96 kilowatts with a six-speed manual
transmission we tested the stronger
gasoline-powered engine it pulls the car
from 0 to 100 km/h in 8.9 seconds the
230 Newton meters maximum torque come
into play from upwards of 1,750 revs per
minute and give the little D S plenty of
zip
eNOS thinks the ninety six kilowatt
engine is ideal for the car even in
sixth gear she had enough power and
reserve to make driving on the Autobahn
fun the designer edition is also
available as a convertible a soft black
fabric top takes the place of the white
roof
the special edition is limited to only
200 cars worldwide that works out to
just ten hardtop and 15 convertible
versions of the nearly 4 metre long
super mini for the German market
exclusive design has its price our test
vehicle costs twenty-seven thousand
three hundred seventy euros in Germany
that's roughly five thousand euros more
than the best-equipped normal ds3 model
with an identical motor the designer has
left her signature on the interior as
well
the granite blue grained leather seats
pick up on the three color airmail theme
the carpet mats are edged with the same
three colored cord the bright red accent
seen outside appears again for the
entire length of the dashboard
penis realizes that design doesn't
necessarily follow logical rules for
instance even if the center console is
fitted with a touchscreen the menu
selections work by pressing buttons down
below and not along the sides as we
might expect the buttons for the
air-conditioning are right where they
belong
the indicator has a little round screen
of its own
[Music]
here this time the instrument cluster is
a bit too conventional for eanes taste
she'd expected more from a designer car
dynamic indicators for example that
allow you to choose from a range of
designs whose Oh already offers
something along those lines in its three
thousand eight GT where the driver uses
a little roller on the steering wheel to
select the style of instrument cluster
[Music]
but then the ds3 has a perfume dispenser
and an illuminated mirror set in the Sun
Visor enos points out that while car
buyers normally pick out their
customization options from a catalog DS
Commission's a trendy designer and gives
the resulting special edition an
attractive name she thinks it goes
perfectly with ds's own philosophy after
all since when has positioned its sub
brand as a car maker that highly values
exclusive design
[Music]
since it was rolled out in 2011 the VW
up has developed into a popular
companion for the city and the country
it's compact size and maneuverability
are its identifying traits with the
natural gas variant of the Eco up the
mini car shows its thrifty side
they're equal Manawa Schaefer says
little distinguishes the ego up from its
brothers as you notice when driving it
has a little less power than the 1 liter
gasoline engine but in daily usage
that's not noticeable it's just as
maneuverable as the other models too but
those expecting a great leap forward and
sportiness from the ego up won't find it
it needs sixteen point three seconds to
accelerate from zero to 100 kilometres
an hour no wonder since under the hood
is only a 50 kilowatt engine that
doesn't reach its maximum torque of 90
Newton meters until it produces 3000
revs
[Music]
the up has an environmentally-friendly
engine for an affordable price of just
under 13,000 euros in Germany in this
car the gas pump is the source of joy
fueling up is child's play the inlet
pipes for gasoline and natural gas are
next to each other
the natural gas tank holds 11 kilograms
enough for around 300 kilometers next to
it the 10 liter gasoline tank Amano
Motel says the Eco up has to reserve
gasoline tank but it's mostly untouched
when it's colder than 10 below zero
Celsius or the driver had just pumped in
natural gas than the gasoline engine
will ignite first after a short while
the natural gas takes over the only
thing the driver notices something gauge
needle shifts from the gasoline area to
the natural gas indicator fundamental
eyes in the air cuspid I thundered the
eco up is especially popular in Italy in
2016 about one third of the up sold had
natural gas engines and Germany far
fewer ups drive with natural gas only
around 3% weak infrastructure is
certainly a reason only 900 of Germany's
14,500 gas stations sell natural gas
[Music]
after the facelifted underwent last year
the outer appearance of the up has
become more individualistic from the
bumper through the headlights with LED
daytime running lights to the side
mirrors with integrated flashing lights
the whole design has been sharpened or
redone there are also new exterior
colors contrasting roof colors exterior
stickers and colored rims to choose from
a point here emmanuel tells us that even
though the natural gas tank is below the
trunk it still has lots of space for a
city car
[Music]
the center console has an optional
smartphone integration plug in the
device or connect via bluetooth and the
Volkswagen app turns the smartphone into
an infotainment system with a navigation
function and onboard computer the seats
with integrated headrests are modern and
upbeat - yeah amano says the Eco up
doesn't claim to be a race car but it's
great for the environment and your
wallet with 300 miles driving range for
about eleven years most gas and diesel
vehicles can't hope to compete with that
you do have to make frequent trips to
the recharging station and natural gas
isn't available at all service stations
in Germany it's a shame that this
environmentally friendly alternative
isn't getting more attention
[Music]
this is Toyota's new crossover SUV the C
HR with its futuristic look it's an
instant stand out among the brands
generally unspectacular range it's
available in three versions we took the
style selection variant for a spin car
testa undulate zimmelman points out that
this model was rolled out from initial
design to volume production in less than
three years CHR stands for coupe a high
rider
it was slated for release under Toyotas
North American sub brand scion but with
science demise Toyota gave it a brand
new name for worldwide distribution bed
veidt's the [ __ ] I burn well its angular
lines and brawny front the CHR
undeniably radiates sheer power the many
corners in its silhouette disguised the
compact length of four point three
meters the fenders also suit the young
design the backseat door handles are
elegantly integrated into the c-pillar
just beneath the roofline
the outward protruding taillights lend
the car a modern self-confident
appearance
[Music]
in darkness EHR Andre says is available
in Germany with either a 1.2 liter
turbocharged four-cylinder engine or a
hybrid engine for 3,000 euros extra the
approximately 110 kilowatt 2 liter
engine is only available in the US but
Andre regrets that neither the American
nor the German market CHR is equipped
with a really powerful turbocharged
engine taking 10.9 seconds to accelerate
from 0 to 100 kilometers an hour
the Toyota CHR isn't as sporty as it
looks though sluggish it scores points
for low fuel consumption at just 6
liters per 100 kilometers it's suitable
for longer journeys
[Music]
[Applause]
I just met Andre remarks he was
astounded by how good the CH arse
interior looks the lacquered components
really make it smart often guns and
Helvetica it's Nouveau and these
imitation seams of course this is a
really sewn leather but it looks really
great there's a good the only thing he
criticizes are the sat-nav software and
graphics which he thinks look a bit
outdated so nine bits in hangar got our
test car has a heated steering wheel
the gauges match the rest of the
futuristic interior
the central console is tidy but about
the only place to stow things is in the
doors the color of the seats matches the
dashboard their lower back support makes
them very comfortable
[Music]
Andre says that there are various ways
of breaking when approaching a curve or
a traffic light even that's the VEX
study one is to shift down and let the
transmission slow the car but that jolts
the car making it out of balance and
putting where on the mechanical parts
one does get off statistic or if you're
an experienced driver you can double
clutch but it's not so easy to find the
perfect pressure points at the same time
on all three pedals its affinity this
thing happens to your target dot that's
why Toyota installed the IMT system a
fancy name for an automatic double
clutching system when you shift down the
car automatically uses target and fuel
bursts to adjust the revs between the
transmission and the engine so that the
car uses the engine braking effect
without jerking or wear and tear or a
mere four Slice before Tyler the motor
brands become not sync on the Toyota CHR
went on sale in January 2017 in Germany
starting at about twenty two thousand
euros
[Music]
Andre says the CHR is a good car of
course but he would have preferred it
without the unnecessarily high ground
clearance and with a bigger sporty-er in
general he thinks this design would fit
a sporty compact whether an SUV needs
such an aggressive design is another
question that stymied I understood next
time on Drive it a new SUV from Opel we
touched the Grantland X and autonomous
driving from Audi testing the a8 with a
traffic jam pilot
[Music]
you